welcome back to grammar unfiltered
hosted by me josh smith and today we're
joined by
a living queen and star of the new movie
locked down
it's anne hathaway
how are you i'm doing all right and
yourself i'm doing good
i mean i love the movie it's amazing now
i'm doing better
thank you for saying that
hi paxton we heard london's in total
lockdown we are all locked in the
psychological prison of burning
aloneness how's linda
she's somewhere in the house is there
some type of issue
what i loved about it is it so reflects
the experience we've all
been through and the very personal
aspects of being locked down
and for parts of it i found it quite
triggering in places as well
to think about that experience what it's
been like what was probably the most
triggering aspect of filming it
for you and reflecting on your own
journey during this time
i mean i love screaming into the pillow
that
felt great and um
and it was not in the script it was just
one take i was just like well let me
just do this thing that i i have done
this year
and um i i finished the take and doug
had this really like
cool glint in his eyes and he went do it
again
so that part was was i think just you
know
a business on top bedtime on bottom that
was that felt very true
but in terms of what you were talking
about in terms of being triggering the
hardest scene to film was the scene
where i had to fire a bunch of people on
zoom the nice people that i fired they
were fired because of me
it's not about the virus it's about who
i am and what i
do for a living you fired them well
thank you is that a glass of wine
yes yeah it is that that was a really um
that was a really painful day just
because
i i know people have gone through it i
know on both sides
of it and um and just knowing that we
were representing something that was
way too real that that was hard
and i think it's a really special kind
of like memory
of our mental health journeys through
that time and the time we're still
experiencing as well
how's that journey been for you of your
own mental health and looking after
yourself how have you gone about that
and navigated that journey
i've really discovered a new level of
gentleness
with myself and with other people you
know i've always been very driven
um and and i still am but i think
sometimes the way that i would get
myself motivated wasn't
it it wasn't always the healthiest
approach the most
the most gentle dental approach so i
just feel like
i'm i'm just softer with myself my
understanding of what it means to be a
human being
i think has expanded and um because i
think i used to
seek to define myself by my best days
and now i i don't do that anymore i kind
of accept all of it
and and certainly in the beginning of
lockdown i was putting all this pressure
on myself to be fine because
like look i don't want to draw too thick
a line under it but i'm i'm
i'm not having the same problems as
other people and i wasn't worried about
where my next meal was coming from i
wasn't worried about
having a roof over my head and because
of those things i thought that it meant
that
i didn't have the right to feel anxious
or scared or any of those things
and that was putting an extra layer of
pressure on me that i couldn't
take and so i had to learn that where
i had to learn that it was okay to talk
about being anxious and being scared and
and all of those things and that i and
that i was going to have to just be
nicer to myself and make room for myself
to feel those things whatever else
happened to be true as well yeah because
it makes you feel less alone when you
talk about experience as well because i
think the characters
we do speak of this experience of the
idea of loneliness and being alone and
being isolated as well like
that feeling of isolation and being
alone it's
something we don't necessarily talk
about and that concept of loneliness
needs to be talked about more as well
don't you think
i i do think so and i you know i'm just
going to be very open about it um early
on in lockdown i was supposed to be on a
group zoom and i had an anxiety attack
and um i couldn't make it and i
decided to write everybody afterwards it
was unusual that i wouldn't be on it and
i
and i decided to write everyone
afterwards and just be honest about what
had happened
and my my people were there for me
and they opened up and they shared their
own experiences with it they shared me
with me their tips they offered you know
they reached out they followed up and i
just realized that i was
i was more loved than i had allowed that
i had actually realized because of that
and if i just kind of papered over it
and said oh no everything's fine i just
you know something came up or the kids
if i'd done that i wouldn't have under
had that understanding
of of how extraordinary the people that
are in my life really are
you know i mean i had that moment over a
murder mystery zoom i had a breakdown
when i was like the merger was like i
just can't
do this anymore but actually it was so
refreshing to be honest about it rather
than trying to paint over the cracks and
be like oh i'm absolutely fine
yeah no we're not we're we're and look
in some days we are fine
and you know what enjoy those days
because as we've learned from this past
year
it's really part of it's it's really
natural that we're going to have days
when we're not and we know that those
days are coming too so do your best to
enjoy the ones where you feel like
okay i'm actually on top of the water
today and i think that's what's so
powerful to see this reflected back on
the screen so we can see that there's
other people going for it that's the
powerful thing isn't it
that's the ho that was the hope of this
one you know that's and that's the hope
of it and that's
i for me that's always the hope of
storytelling is that it makes people
feel connected
and that it might make people feel less
alone um and it might even help
help them make sense of things that they
haven't had the words for i know that
reading stephen knight's script
it helped me navigate my own feelings
because he's such a brilliant writer and
getting to say those lines did
kind of i don't know give me a new
perspective on certain things and
the new perspective of how great
screaming into a pillow is
it's really really good especially when
your kids just want to scare
them mommy's fine i've been furloughed
now there is literally zero purpose to
my life
i'm going to get provisions we need milk
bread
how many asses have you got piss off if
you could go back
to a stage during this year and be a
friend to yourself
when would it have been and what would
you want to say to yourself if you could
be that friend to you
god i think i think in the in the
beginning i think
um i think and i wouldn't have said
anything i think i just would have
like held my hands and let myself cry
you know i think that there was this um
there was this pressure because you have
to understand i've been a working
actress
for some time now i haven't spent this
much time at home
since i was 16 years old so there's just
a lot of things that i hadn't done in 20
years that i didn't
know how to do and that i've had you
know and so
that there's that process of just
learning something for the first time
and learning how not to be embarrassed
by what you don't know
um i think i probably just would have
reassured myself that don't worry come
january 1st
you are going to make a paleo quiche
from scratch without looking at a recipe
you're going to figure this out
and so then on those days when i just
kind of felt hopeless at everything i
wouldn't maybe i wouldn't have
been so hard on myself yeah it's also
interesting because when you define your
identity so much by what you do as a job
right i think we all do this
in this modern day context when you have
that removed
you're like oh god who am i as a person
you realize things you never realized
about yourself before
and you realize how unhealthy it is to
define yourself by your job
you know and so i think i i i know i
felt that way i'm sure a lot of us felt
that way that
my my understanding of myself became
more personal this year it became so
much less about what was going on
outside
it became um it became so much less
about what was going on in my career and
so much more about what was going on in
my home
and with yourself and that's amazing and
thank you so much for opening up about
your journey this year
and thank you so much for the movie
you're incredible it's been an honor
talking to you and just keep slaying it
babe
thank you so much for that shirt it made
my day
i mean just i brought it for my
boyfriend after like two minutes i'm
boring this thanks
oh you sound sweet i pass on the
compliments to him i love it
bye look after yourself you too we have
a situation
all the major department stores are
closing they want everything over the
next four days
we have a problem at harrods we have
four million dollars worth of jewelry
someone's gonna have to pack the
valuables up i believe you are a man who
can be trusted yeah i am
yeah i can be trusted it's gonna have to
be something that we trust
so that means inevitably is gonna be me